MALE SPEAKER: Good afternoon.
Welcome to Talks at Google.
Today, it's my great pleasure
to introduce local author,
local to Boston, Heidi Pitlor.
HEIDI PITLOR: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
HEIDI PITLOR: Thanks
for having me.
MALE SPEAKER: Thanks for coming.
HEIDI PITLOR: My pleasure.
MALE SPEAKER: No, our pleasure.
HEIDI PITLOR: No, mine.
MALE SPEAKER: Actually, this
is Heidi's second time here.
She was here last week for
David Duchovny as our guest.
Heidi worked for nine years as
an editor at Houghton Mifflin.
Since then, she's worked
for another nine years
as co-editor of the Best
American Short Stories
of the Year, so you've probably
read more short fiction,
at least American short fiction,
than anybody else probably
anywhere can claim.
HEIDI PITLOR: I hope so.
If anyone else reads more,
I think they need help.
I need help, so they
definitely need help.
MALE SPEAKER: She's
also found time
to write two novels, "The
Birthdays" and her most
recent novel, which you have
copies of, "The Daylight
Marriage," which
I read in advance
and in another month or two,
I may recover from reading.
It's pretty strong
stuff, should be
available only
with a prescription
or to people over-- I
don't know, 18, 16, 14.
Seriously, it's powerful stuff.
So with no further ado, Heidi.
HEIDI PITLOR: Thank you
again for having me.
It's a real pleasure to be here.
I'll sum up the
book for you, and I
thought I would read a few pages
just to give you a sense of it,
and then maybe we could talk
about it, or anything else you
might want to talk about today.
So this novel is about
a married couple.
They've been married
for a long time.
They have a 15-year-old
and an eight-year-old,
a 15-year-old
daughter named Janine
and an eight-year-old
son named Ethan.
Their marriage has
grown strained.
They are not super thrilled
with each other anymore,
and the book starts
out with them getting
into an argument,
a heated, you know,
your typical
married couple being
pushed to the extreme argument.
So where I'm going to start
is-- the characters' names
are Lovell is the husband
and Hannah is the wife.
They have just finished
their argument.
Hannah has run off into the
son's room, whose name is
Ethan, and we're
with Lovell now,
the aftermath of the fight,
the moments after, in his mind.
"He faced Hannah's
pillow, bunched
into a ball in its ivory case at
the far corner of the mattress.
The poison that they had kept
stored away inside themselves,
this toxic stew that
had expanded for years,
had finally boiled over and out.
Janine pushed the
door open an inch
and leaned her face forward.
She peered around the room.
Her hair sat in a brutalized
tangle at the top of hear head.
'You all done?' she asked.
'Yes,' he said, unable
to face her right now.
'Let's get you back
to sleep,' he managed.
If he was able to
seem calm and steady,
she might believe that he was.
'I wasn't sleeping,' she said,
keeping herself behind the door
as he approached.
'Of course not.
I'm sorry.
That was no good.' He had
learned that the more he tried
to explain away their battles
to her, the worse they sounded.
'Where's mom?' she asked.
Hannah slept in
Ethan's room whenever
she had trouble sleeping,
which was most nights.
'Probably in your brother's
room.' Janine stepped carefully
around the door and
in front of him.
'Is she OK,' she asked.
His daughter could
be surprisingly
maternal toward Hannah.
'Your mother's fine,'
he said automatically.
'I'm fine too,' he added,
not that she had asked.
He followed her to her bedroom.
He tucked her in, although
she flinched at his touch,
and then he sat beside
her on her mattress.
At last, she closed her eyes.
He stayed a moment, looking
down at his daughter, the wisps
of light hair across
her temple, her lips
barely parted as she
lay there on her side.
She may not have been sleeping.
She may have been pretending,
but he did not say anything.
He was grateful that she
allowed this right now,
that she was letting him just
stay here and look at her.
The early days, those
first few months
of friendship, when all that
he knew of Hannah Monroe
fit inside a daydream.
She had grown up on
Martha's Vineyard
and now lived alone in
one of her parents' two
off island homes, a four bedroom
brownstone on Clarendon where
a tree sized grandfather
clock stood guard just
inside the front door.
She kept a rosewood
box of [INAUDIBLE]
honey caramel truffles on her
coffee table at all times.
She collected antique
glass perfume bottles
that were rounded and spiny,
swirled with primordial indigo,
and deep, opaque emerald.
She was passionate
about the Red Sox
but hated the Patriots
and football in general.
She gave the
impression of a swan,
regal but fragile, lovely
and thoughtful and capable
of sudden wildness.
She was the most feminine,
self assured, compelling female
that he had ever met.
She called him one
night with a ticket
to a game against the Blue
Jays the next afternoon.
'My friend just backed out.
I'd have called you
sooner,' she began.
He immediately accepted,
and because she had a car
and he did not, they agreed
that she would come pick him up
before the game.
The next afternoon, she arrived
at his apartment in Brighton
wearing a ski jacket, her neck
swaddled in lumpy, hairy scarf.
Her nostrils were
pink and inflamed
and she sounded congested.
Had he missed it over the phone?
He led her inside and
offered to make her some tea.
'We don't have to leave this
second, do we?' he asked.
'No,' she shrugged,
'not just yet.'
He hung up her jacket while
she unraveled her scarf.
He filled a mug with water
and put it in the microwave.
They sat across from each
other at the wobbly card
table in his kitchen.
Down the hall, his
roommate Paul labored
with his trombone scales, unable
to reach the higher notes.
Hannah's hair pooled
down onto her shoulders
and ran over her small
breasts, down over her stomach,
stopping at her waist.
She had these light filled
eyes and a black eyelash clung
to the side ridge of her nose.
She made considerable
attempts to sniff back all
that was inside her sinuses.
He went to find a box of
tissues, and when he returned,
he asked, 'You sure you're
up for a baseball game
outside?' 'I'll be fine.
The season's almost over.
We have to go.
Thanks,' she said, as
she reached for the box.
She asked, 'have you ever been
in love?' Her crazy questions,
always non-sequiturs,
still blindsided him.
'I'm not sure.
I don't think so,' he said.
Paul groaned and started again
at the beginning of his scale.
The microwave beeped and
Lovell found a box of Lipton
that Paul's mother had
left on her last visit.
Lovell set the mug
down before Hannah
and she brought it to her
mouth for a dainty sip.
The table tottered
beneath her arms
and she wrapped her
fingers around the mug
to protect the tea or her lap.
He found an empty box of Frosted
Flakes with the recycling,
folded it into awkward
fourths, and jammed it
under the shortest table leg.
Once he took his seat again,
she looked off beyond him.
'So what exactly does it
feel like,' he said at last.
'Oh, you'd know,' she said.
'That's what they always
say, you just know,' he said.
The trombone grew louder, a
whiny, embarrassing little
brother in the next room.
I'm here, I'm here, I'm here.
'The first night I met him,
we slept together,' she said.
This jerk named Doug
Bowen had been her fiance
just a few months ago.
She talked about him a lot.
'And the next night
too,' she said.
'I probably shouldn't
admit that.'
How to respond?
Anyway, Lovell had a
chemical oceanography paper
due the next day.
He should have been finalizing
his isotope indicators,
proofreading.
He had 100 things he should have
been doing other than sitting
here with this girl.
She said, 'you've
never done that,
slept with someone right
away?' She made one last,
heartbreaking attempt to
breathe through her nose.
He had, but he didn't think it
was love, nothing like that.
'What's the right
answer,' he said.
'There's no right
or wrong,' she said.
'Well, I guess there was this
one girl and we almost did.
We got really close,' he said,
'but I didn't want to hurt her
later on, so I held off.
I mean, we both did.'
'Ah, the right answer
anyway,' she said.
He watched her guide the
tea bag around the water
by its paper tag.
He was a gawky, long
limbed PhD candidate
from semi rural Maine.
He was allergic to shellfish,
and in his rare free time,
he did little other than
monopolize his roommate's
Nintendo.
She was light years
out of his league.
'Now the wrong
answer,' she said.
'Yes, we went ahead and slept
together but I didn't really
love her,' he said.
'Tell me more,' she said.
'She,' he began.
A section of his chest withered.
He felt protective of it.
'No.'
'No,' she said.
He shook his head.
'Good for you,' she
said, and nodded.
'Really, it's none of my
business.' She finished her tea
and drew a deep breath,
this time through her mouth.
She sat up straighter and
looked at him anew as if only
now realizing he was in
the room with her, Lovell
and not someone else.
'You're a good person,
aren't you?' she said.
'I try,' he said.
She studied his face,
side to side, up and down.
'I could use a good person.
I need someone good in my
life right now,' she said.
'Good,' he said sadly.
He had landed on that
brotherly side of the spectrum.
'Oh,' she said.
'Oh what?' His face was hot.
It was too late.
'Nothing,' she said carefully,
but she half smiled,
embarrassed, maybe
hopefully intrigued.
'Are we ready to go?'
Now, Lovell checked
one more time
to see whether both cars
were in the driveway.
When he saw that they
were, he headed downstairs
for his laptop and
answered some work emails.
There would be no point
trying to fall asleep
after this night.
He skimmed the newspaper,
considered finding his banjo,
which he had not
played in a few years.
He flipped through
some magazines.
He eventually made his way
back upstairs and into bed.
Later, he heard the Mechener
kid on this bike outside
and the smack of newspapers
landing on driveways,
as well as the sound of
the milk truck screeching
down Winter Street, that
compact, joyless, bovine
woman-- Hannah's
term, It had made
him howl-- who left
bottles of organic milk
on people's porches once a week.
In the morning, Hannah remained
steely for the brief time
that he saw her before
he had to leave for work,
but she allowed him to give
her a quick kiss goodbye,
and he hoped this might
be a precursor to a truce.
He turned his
thoughts to all that
lay ahead of him at his office.
The numbers from Pago
Pago would screw up
his estimates of potential
intensity of tropical cyclones.
Hurricane Katrina
had garnered him
and his theory some
attention, but still, there
were plenty of naysayers
in the government.
Lovell arrived at
Mass Environmental
and the day began" Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER:
Thank you for that.
HEIDI PITLOR: Sure.
MALE SPEAKER: I love the prose.
HEIDI PITLOR: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: So I'm curious.
I would like to get
into the differences
between short fiction
and extended fiction.
You're a novelist,
but you've spent
most of your career
at this point,
or a significant
part of it, basically
judging short fiction.
When you were an editor
at Houghton Mifflin,
did you work a lot
with short fiction
or did you just stumble
into short fiction?
HEIDI PITLOR: Well, before I
worked at Houghton Mifflin,
I got my MFA at Emerson College,
and most writing students
start out by studying
short fiction because it's
a very workshoppable form.
It's a very digestible form.
So I guess I started
with short stories,
and that might have
been my true love.
When I became an
editor, I did work
on short story
collections and novels.
I did a little
nonfiction, but because I
worked with a lot
of new writers,
that tends to be the form
people start out with,
so I did some of them.
A story collection is
not the preferred form.
It wasn't then.
It's not now.
Publishers say, that's great.
Do you have a novel after that?
So that tends to be the way to
get some writers in the door.
I was an assistant but
worked on a book called
"The Interpreter of
Maladies," and it
was so gratifying to see that
this was a story collection.
We published it as
paperback original.
It was a very modest
acquisition and it
doesn't matter what form it is.
Great writing, I think,
is great writing,
and I still feel that way.
My day job is short fiction,
my writing is longer fiction,
but in my mind, they're
almost interchangeable.
It's more about the writing,
to the, and the prose,
and the quality of it than
the form that it comes in.
MALE SPEAKER: I've
always imagined,
and I've never gone
through a writing program,
so I could be
completely misinformed,
but I've always imagined that
the short story as a form
has always required
a different skill set
or always has its
own set of rules
as opposed to longer fiction.
Is there any truth to that?
HEIDI PITLOR: Yeah.
I mean, it's such a
different feeling to write.
At the beginning
of writing a novel,
you walk into a big, empty
house, and you think,
I have to fill all these rooms.
And when you're writing a
story, you're in a room,
and usually, you
can see at least one
or two walls, a closet.
You can sense what
the parameters are.
I think in novels, so
many new writers stumble
when they are over
ambitious and you think,
I've got to fill this
whole damn house.
Let's throw in some
history, let's throw
in a lot of characters.
I think you see a lot of
novelists really stuffing it
full because of that fear
when you walk in, that fear
of emptiness, of white
space on the page.
I'm forgetting what
your question was.
MALE SPEAKER:
Basically, differences
in potentially both the
form of a short story
and the skills required
to produce both forms.
HEIDI PITLOR: You know,
they're different,
and I do think writers
tend to either fall on one
side of the wall or the other.
You're either a short story
writer or a novel writer.
In short stories, obviously,
every word matters more.
There's not the room for
tangents and digressions
that there is in novels.
The flip side of
that is in novels,
there's a lot of space to fill.
I think it was really
interesting writing this book
because it's short and it's,
I think, kind of tight.
I cut away a lot
of the digressions
that were in there earlier.
Maybe this is kind of a hybrid,
what's called a novella.
It's being published as a novel.
I'm not sure if I'd say
it's different skill
set or a different mindset.
I think it's a very
different mindset
and some people are
more comfortable in one
than in the other.
I've seen a lot of story writers
make the transition awkwardly.
I've seen a lot of novelists
try and squeeze themselves
into short stories, and you
can tell a lot of times.
Granted, that's my job and all
I do is read short stories,
and I'm very critical
of this stuff,
but I do think you can
tell where people's comfort
level is.
MALE SPEAKER:
Commercially speaking,
I won't identify
the person, but I
know there's at least one
person in this room who's
an aspiring fiction writer.
HEIDI PITLOR: Oh good.
MALE SPEAKER: You mentioned that
at Houghton Mifflin, at least,
and I assume most
publishers, that,
if I understood
correctly, it's easier
to get published as a novelist
than as a short story writer.
What advice would you give
the aspiring writer of fiction
because I can also imagine
going the route of publishing
short stories in
journals, McSweeney's
and different places, and then
possibly, having done that,
outlining a novel, workshopping
that, and going to a publisher
and saying, I have these
short story credits.
Here are three chapters
and an outline.
What do you think?
Or going to an agent.
Is that a legitimate way to go?
HEIDI PITLOR: That's
the standard route
is to write short stories,
to try to get them published
or win some awards or
do some residencies.
There are all these great
writing centers-- GrubStreet
in Boston, there's Bread Loaf.
There's a lot of different
residencies and programs
you can apply to.
So to go that route,
writing short stories,
gather some credits,
try to find an agent,
put together a collection.
Usually, you'll be
asked to write a novel.
I'm a big fan of-- I don't
think breaking rules as much
as following what it is that
you really want to write.
So if you want to write stories,
by all means, go that route.
It's not easy to get
stories published.
I'm not sure why
exactly that is.
There's a ton of literary
magazines out there,
but it's really hard to
get stories published.
I've talked to umpteen writers.
When I used to write stories, I
had a hard time finding people
to publish them.
It's a funny world,
and I'm not sure
if it's because a
lot of the magazines
are published by
universities, so you
get grad students reading the
piles of stories that come in
and they might not have a
sense of if a story's trying
to take a risk.
You see less risky stuff out
there in some of the journals.
But to go back to
the question, I
think it's important
to figure out
what you really want to write.
If you want to write a
science fiction novel
and that is your
end goal, screw it.
Get to that.
If you want to
write a prose poem,
you have to find
where that energy is,
where that thing that
keeps you interested is.
It's hard these days.
Who wants to write?
There's so much to distract us.
You at Google should know this.
The whole world is full
of attention thieves,
so you have to find what
is just gripping to you
and allow yourself to
write that, I think,
no matter what it is.
There's always going
to be prescribed routes
to go about this and
that, and then you
hear these stories of the
most successful people
didn't go that route.
J. K. Rowling, people
who wrote on the sly.
I think, again, the key is to
figure out what works for you
and to respect your own
inner voice, in a way.
It's a hard thing
to do these days,
but I think it's important.
MALE SPEAKER: Now, in terms of
the Best American Short Fiction
of the Year, you typically
work with well known writers,
most recently, Pulitzer
Prize winner Jennifer Egan,
to produce those.
Do they pull their
weight or are they
just big names to
put on the covers?
You don't have to
answer that honestly.
How does the process work?
HEIDI PITLOR: They
definitely pull their weight.
I mean, I have a
different weight.
So what I do is
I read everything
that's published in
the calendar year
by an American journal
that is distributed,
which encompasses a huge amount.
MALE SPEAKER: How many
stories would that be?
HEIDI PITLOR: I read between
3,000 and 4,000 a year,
so I'm really picky
and critical and awful.
I'm kind of your worst nightmare
reader because I have kids
and I write and I
have no patience.
So either I'm with you on
page one or two or forget it.
So I read all these stories.
They all get sent to me.
They just come in.
I'm on everybody's
circulation list.
I read them all.
I pull 120 of them, and then I
said those to my guest editor
who pulls 20.
They pick 20.
And everyone's different.
We work together sometimes
more, sometimes less.
They're the big name.
I let them decide how
the process should go.
But it's the world's
greatest job.
It really is.
I get to be a one on one book
club with just an incredibly
successful and talented
writer every year
and have it be
someone different.
It's fascinating.
It's completely,
completely fascinating.
Their processes
are all different.
I never know what to expect.
When I started this
job, I thought,
Alice Sebold, who wrote
"The Lovely Bones,"
I pulled all these violent
stories about kids and girls,
and none of them.
She was really into historical
fiction, and I thought,
I have no idea.
So then I began to just say,
I just need to rely on my gut,
pick things that I
like, not try to please
the other person, which is such
a good life lesson sometimes.
And it's really
unpredictable each year,
but there's a lot of reading,
and they do a lot of reading,
too.
They have to read 120 of
these stories and pick 20.
And some years, it's
easier than others.
There can be a lot of
back and forth between us.
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
But ultimately, the
20 that they pick
are the ones that
will go on the book?
HEIDI PITLOR: Yes.
I write a foreword.
They write an introduction.
It's kind of nice for
me because if people
complain about the stories, I
say, well, blame Jenny Egan.
I had nothing to do with it.
It's nice not to have
the full load rest on me.
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
Always good to have a backup.
Anything else you
want us to know
about anything else you do?
HEIDI PITLOR: Oh my god.
Well, everybody sit back.
MALE SPEAKER:
Totally open ended.
HEIDI PITLOR: I don't think so.
Do you guys have
any questions maybe?
I always like
knowing what you want
to hear so I'm not yammering
into the ether so much,
so go ahead.
AUDIENCE: I would love to ask
you a question about this book.
I have read some
reviews on the book
and I understand this is
very emotional and very hard
on the reader, in a
sense, and I really
look forward, and also
am a little bit afraid.
I imagine a lot of readers can
relate to it because people
are in relationships,
people tend to argue,
people tend to have remorse
after their arguments.
And usually, it
doesn't go that bad,
but this is like not
living out a fantasy,
but reading about
some characters
and seeing what
happens [INAUDIBLE].
This might be a really
good lesson for us.
But even if I don't learn
anything from the book,
if I enjoy it, then
it's worth reading.
I was wondering
what made you choose
such an intense,
emotional subject.
How did you weigh your
risk of having something
that readers take
months to recover from?
And also, how did
you cope emotionally
with the burden of having
to be in the position
of the characters and having
to write out and go back
over and over and rewrite,
really reliving what they
are living through in the book?
What did it mean for you to
write from the point of view
of these characters?
HEIDI PITLOR: So a few answers.
I wrote my first book.
It was published
in 2006, and it is
a novel about a family
full of pregnant people,
and it's kind of a family drama.
It's set on an island in Maine.
And after I published it, a
well known writer came up to me
and he said, you know
what I love about a book?
And I said, what?
He said, well, I usually
like when something happens.
And I said, wow, thanks.
I just turned purple
and crept away.
But it stuck with me and I
thought, I love my first book
but it doesn't have a huge plot.
It was more of a psychological
exploration of a family.
And I thought, I wouldn't
mind writing a big bang book.
It's always been
important to me,
and this sounds really basic,
but to keep your reader
turning pages.
It's a really fundamental thing.
I think a lot of readers
lose sight of that.
Once again, these days, there
are so many distractions
out there.
A lot of people aren't reading
as much as they used to,
and it's important to
keep your reader engaged.
So I had that in the back of
my mind after my first book.
I got pregnant with
twins and my husband
and I lived out in a small
town, and I took this new job,
and I was just home
bound with twins,
which was really hard on me.
We were isolated.
We were what felt like out
in the middle of nowhere.
It was a strange place to be.
All I knew is I wanted to write
something that had a big story.
And around this time,
the Lacey Peterson story
was in the news a
lot, and I started
noticing there's all these
stories of these very
beautiful women who go
missing and something grizzly
happens to them, and why are
they getting so much coverage?
Why are these stories
getting so much coverage?
So I kind of dipped a toe in
this story, and then maybe
a month later, a woman who
lived in my town was shot,
she and her young baby
were shot in her bed
by her British husband,
and the press just
flooded into our town.
And I was like a crazy person.
I was completely
obsessed with this case.
They lived less than a
mile and a half from us.
Our town center, our nice
little, bucolic town green
filled up with reporters.
And I watched this whole thing
and it just got under my skin.
And I thought, why has
this become a dark fairy
tale for us?
Why do people lap this up--
the media, the readers.
Why do I care?
I'm sort of a smart person.
I'm literary.
I don't usually read
tabloid news so much,
but I could not get
enough of this case.
So that was my in
door to this story.
I had these things
swirling around in my head,
and I started writing it, and
the darker story was really
part of a back story as I was
writing the first few drafts.
There was a nicer,
happier story around it,
which eventually fell away
with the help of my editor, who
saw that the book really
was about the darker,
more uncomfortable
story, and it was
OK to let that sit
alone on the page.
I didn't set out for it to
be this emotional and this
intense.
I think it needed to be.
It's a weird thing as a
writer, and it probably
sounds a little bit
crazy, but a book
needs to be a certain thing.
Your characters
speak to you in a way
that can override
what your needs are.
And so this thing took
over my life for so long.
It was very painful to
write, but it was also
when I had finished
it in the way
that it needed to be finished,
it was incredibly rewarding.
And I felt nervous because
I thought, oh god, I'm
going to send this dark
thing out into the world,
but I also thought of many
other dark books that did OK.
I think people can
handle intensity
and I think it's important
to trust your reader.
I think not enough people
in various businesses do,
and I think people at the end
of the day want to be moved.
They want catharsis
in their reading.
So maybe this was all
just justification,
but I clung to it, and
now we have this book,
if that answers that.
Any other questions?
Anything anyone
wants to talk about?
MALE SPEAKER: Actually,
I had one more,
and you touched on it.
Taking off of your
question, certainly,
there are at least a few
superficial similarities
to another dark book-- you know
where I'm going with this--
which has gotten--
HEIDI PITLOR: I have no idea.
MALE SPEAKER: Well,
you might have
heard there was a book that
was on the Times bestseller
list for about 19 or 20 years,
seemingly, called Gone Girl.
HEIDI PITLOR: Oh, that one.
MALE SPEAKER: I
think they might have
made a little movie about it.
There are a few at least
superficial resemblances
between your book and that one.
Was that something that
came up during the editing
process or the publishing
process with you?
HEIDI PITLOR: That's
a great question.
So yes, yes, yes, yes.
So this book took me
a long time to write,
and "Gone Girl" was published
I'm not sure what year,
but a few years
into my writing it.
And I thought, uh oh.
I read it and
right away thought,
this is such a different book.
I think "Gone Girl" is an edgy,
wonderful mystery thriller,
funner ride of a book.
Mine has been called
a mystery or thriller
and I don't really think it is.
I think it's
suspenseful and I always
feel a little pretentious
using the word "literary,"
but I think it's literary and
suspenseful and psychological,
but it's not "Gone
Girl" in any way.
The first five pages, maybe
there's a similar premise,
but it goes in such a
wildly different direction.
That said, it's been hard
having that out there.
It feels like the person in
the room, the 800-pound gorilla
that's hanging out with
me during this whole time.
I love "Gone Girl."
I thought it was wonderful.
I loved the movie.
This isn't that book.
I think there's a lot of
desire out there to say,
this is the next
"Gone Girl" or this
is the next whatever
big book out there.
As a writer, you can't
pay attention to that
unless it is the same book.
Once I had read
it, I felt better.
But there's been a lot of
comparisons made in the press,
and I worry with
that together where
there's a lovely quote from
Stephen King on the front.
I worry that the "Gone
Girl" comparison, together
with this great
Stephen King quote,
is going to mislead people.
But at the end of the day,
I guess that's not my job.
My job is to write a book
and worry about the writing,
and then at this
point, it's yours.
It's for the readers,
and I go away and shield
myself a little bit, hopefully.
So that's what I'll
say about that.
MALE SPEAKER: OK.
Fair enough.
Anything else?
AUDIENCE: Have you got any
ideas for another book?
HEIDI PITLOR: I
do, and I'm always
nervous to talk
about it too soon,
but I do and it's much lighter.
I kind of feel like I need
a vacation after this one,
and I worry it might be
so light that if there's
a reader that likes this,
they won't like that.
But again, you can't care about.
You have to just write
what you want to write.
So my main idea is that it's
about happiness and the search
for happiness,
which will probably
mean it'll turn into something
horrible and unhappy,
knowing me, but
I'm going to try.
I need a lighter experience.
Anything else?
Any other questions?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: In your
description of your job,
you seem to read something
like five, six, seven,
eight short stories a day,
which brings me to a question.
Usually, when I finish a book,
be it a short story or a novel,
it doesn't matter
what it is about.
I just need to pay my
respect to the book
by just waiting for
a few days before I
switch to another book.
I was wondering how you manage
to do this context switching
so fast, five times a day.
HEIDI PITLOR: I know.
So I have to do mini
switches, or palate cleansers,
I call them.
This is what's made me an
absolute Twitter and Facebook
junkie because it's the
perfect amount of time.
If I read a whole
story, my computer's
there, putz around on Twitter
and Facebook for a bit,
get the mind out,
because I can't afford
to take a longer chunk of time.
There's just too much to read.
At the end of my reading year,
always, there's this avalanche.
No matter how much I try
and stay on top of it
through the year, there's
just this growing pile
that is sitting there
at the end of the year,
and there's a few less
palate cleansers in there.
You learn to do
it after a while,
but you also learn to accept
the fact that you're human,
that you're not perfect.
I always feel like-- you
just feel strange about,
who am I to decide what the
best American short story is?
At some point, all
of us just say,
well, I'm going to
do the best I can
and I'm going to
accept my shortcomings.
There are days where
I'm in a bad mood,
and unfortunately, if
I'm reading your story,
that's the way the world
works, like any job.
There are days where my kids
are driving me crazy or are sick
and I have to read
with the TV blaring
and the water pipes
broken or something.
I'm going into my
10th volume, so I've
learned to forgive
myself in a lot of ways
and at least try to accept
my imperfections on the job.
But that said,
Twitter and Facebook
are my friends for
palate cleansing.
Anyone else have
any other questions?
Go ahead.
AUDIENCE: So between
the two orthogonal tasks
of reading and
reviewing and authoring,
do you find it hard to create
the dividing line here,
where ideas from one aren't
leaking into the other?
HEIDI PITLOR: Absolutely.
I think the best thing to do
is to write first in the day.
I drop my kids off
at school and then go
write, because if I read first,
other voices get into my head.
I try to have a time
separation, whether it's lunch,
go run an errand or something.
But it's really easy to
even subconsciously grab
onto a voice or a
phrase or a character
and have it worm its way through
without even realizing it.
And the other thing
that I think is hard
is that my day job makes me
a really critical reader,
so it's hard not to be
hard on myself as a writer.
It's much easier
for me to revise
than to produce new work.
When you're in that
generative space,
it's almost like being
in a dream state.
You have to turn off every
critical voice in your head
or you're not going
to produce anything.
So that's gotten harder
for me over the years,
and I've revised this for long
enough that it's been awhile.
So writing this new
book feels a little bit
like I've been put in
a sandbox with no toys
and I kind of have
to figure it out.
It's tough, but hopefully
I'll be able to get back
in the mode of it.
Any other questions,
concerns, fears?
MALE SPEAKER: I have
one more, and one more.
I was just wondering.
I would guess you would
be past this stage,
if it ever happened, but at
any point in this career,
have you ever had editors
or agents or writers
themselves say the
equivalent of, please
don't read this story of
mine when your kids are
driving you crazy or something.
I know you've read 10 stories
of mine in the last five years,
but this is the one.
HEIDI PITLOR: Oh yes.
I have authors send me stuff.
And again, I'll read
anything that was published,
but they don't get
to say when I read.
I think it's like any award.
It's the unfortunate
luck of the draw.
I've definitely had people
send me notes saying,
this is the best
story by this author,
and you can't really
take any of it in.
I think I've gotten
to the point where
my kids used to play soccer
at this indoor soccer place.
It was the, loudest,
smelliest, nastiest space.
And I'd sit there
reading my stories,
and all the other moms
were chatting away.
And I think I got really
good at telling right away,
this is a good
story or this isn't.
It becomes this
automatic thing where
there's a switch
flicked or not, and it
becomes easier and easier
the more you do it.
MALE SPEAKER: But
people do politic.
HEIDI PITLOR: People
rally a little bit,
and they're allowed to
rally all they want,
but it's not going to
make any difference to me.
MALE SPEAKER: Sure.
HEIDI PITLOR: Did
you have a question?
AUDIENCE: So as someone
who's read a ton of stories,
it sounds like you have
a good sense for what
it is that makes a good story.
From my perspective of being
a much less avid reader,
there is always this conflict
between a story that's
really strong throughout
and then the ones
that one piece of imagery,
that no matter how
little I'm enjoying it during
the reading, two years later,
I'm still revisiting
[INAUDIBLE].
Do you find that
correlation is there,
or the inverse
correlation, perhaps,
the ones that stick with you
the most versus the ones that
are actually [INAUDIBLE]?
HEIDI PITLOR: They do.
I've started to think in
this very romantic term.
My head is a computer that's
getting really stuffed.
So I don't remember
as much as I used to.
I also should say Houghton
Mifflin is publishing
a book called "100 Years of the
Best American Short Stories,"
and that's coming
out in October.
So along with reading
3,000 to 4,000
of the regular
stories every year,
for the past three
or four years,
I've read every volume of the
book to put together this.
So this computer chip,
whatever is fried.
I mean, there's just not
a lot of specific imagery
that I'm just sitting
around thinking of.
But for my favorite
stories, it's true.
There are moments
that stick with you.
There are lines
What do I think
makes a strong story?
Confident writing,
natural writing.
I wish there were
more humor out there.
I like risk taking.
I'm a big fan of melding of
genres of sci-fi, of dystopia,
or of humor or mystery, as
well as literary fiction.
I like anything
that feels inventive
or new or important or relevant.
I wish more people wrote stories
about technology and science
and the economy.
It's funny.
In short fiction, news
or content of the day
takes a while to
penetrate short fiction.
So now I'm reading a lot of
stories about the Iraq war.
So I always feel like I'm
reading the shadow of what's
happening in the real world
because it takes writers
a while to properly digest
what's going on in the world
and make sense of it and
turn it into art, obviously.
That's basically what
I look for, I think.
That said, good writing
is good writing.
I'm always surprised
when I like a story that
is about nothing, that's
just a great voice
or has great imagery
or characters.
That is incredibly
gratifying, too.
Thank you so much for coming.
This was really fun.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]